herzlich willkommen beim intercity
action kidz vielen dank vielen dank wir
sind genau der richtige mann für ein
action chris habe ich den eindruck es
wird sich jetzt herausstellen genau wie
heißt die strecke mit den meisten
verspätungen saarland rüber b
bayern gurke cnr wie banane dem nrw
banane altbayern gurke kenne ich nicht
das bedürfnis sich in bayern google
kennen sie horst seehofer ist es wird
sicher wieder anzüglich menschenskind
herr van dorst dadurch wird auch die nrw
preis ist die nrw banana wie sonne berge
die platte gemacht wie viele züge sind
2017 ausgefallen
keiner natürlich weil die bahn genügend
funktionierende ersatzzüge hat die im
zweifelsfall umgehend eingesetzt werden
können dann ist es bei 140.000 oder es
kann da nur richtig sagen wie viele der
über 5.000 bahnhöfe gehören nach dem
eigenen bewertungssystem der deutschen
bahn zur spitzen kategorie
selbstverständlich sind alle der über
5.000 bahn will für spitzenmäßig
ausgestattet sind richtig gut
ausgestattet fragen sind sie graffiti
mäßig immer so schön gestaltet ja oder
riechen auch gut die sind richtig fan ja
ich bin totaler fan vor allem abends
wenn ich den uringeruch so richtig war
dann weiß ich es
wieder zu hause wie viele ic züge sind
voll funktionsfähig
selbstverständlich alle so ein zug ist
ja teuer ist wäre ja quatsch wenn er
nicht funktionieren würde
oder b jeder fünfte ich tippe auf jeden
fünften
zu viele ausfallen das ist korrekt jeder
5 und dritter geworden ist nicht
folglich sich aber es ist so ein
bisschen so als hätte ich nur einen
funktionsfähigen finger oder 12345 nur
das ja eigentlich ist es wahrscheinlich
an den fingern essen
also bitte ich habe ich habe diese dinge
gezeigt
rabatt an den fingern oder man denke nur
wenige trauten wissen sie was an gelegen
ist dass sie mich nicht nach der spd
fragen sondern nach den defiziten bei
der deutschen bundesbahn habe ich noch
eine frage es gibt eine neue verbindung
zwischen dresden und berlin schätzen sie
mal wie viel schneller ist diese neue
strecke als dieselbe strecke 1939 also
ich vermute mal dass sie langsamer ist
sie hatten gar nichts von der bahn oder
dass das überrascht ich hätte ich gesagt
diese prognose langsam als 1939 wurde
neue strecke ist also es wäre zu
besonders erstaunlich weil es gibt eine
ganze reihe von bahnstrecken die jetzt
langsamer sind als wie zur zeit der
weimarer republik
das ist so negativ sein das wären sechs
minuten gewesen und wir haben auch
gedacht dass so wenig schätzt niemand ok
schätzen sie mal wie viel schneller ist
diese neue strecke als dieselbe strecke
1939 sechs minuten aber wissen wir dass
sind das ist doch ein quiz da darf man
auch was richtiges sagen amerika
ich habe auch gar keine liste die
anderen banken die bisher eher als
langweilig und es macht einfach kein
spaß tut mir leid ja dann kriegen sie
jetzt ihren gewinn und zwar ist das ein
gutschein von flix bis 19 euro eine
amtszeit gültig damit stecken sie nicht
mehr zu fest sondern im stau
bitte sehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]